The Tree of 40 Fruit is a single fruit tree...
...that grows over 40 different types of stone fruit,...
...including peaches, plums, apricots, nectarines, cherries and almonds.
The idea came from just sort of a fascination with the process of grafting.
When I'd seen it done as a child, it was Dr. Seuss and Frankenstein...
...and just about everything fantastic.
I started traveling around Central New York and New York State...
...to look for different varieties of stone fruit.
Eventually, I was able to find these different heirloom and antique varieties,...
...but they are very rare so I would bring 'em back here to my nursery,...
...graft them onto a tree so that I could continue to use them.
Now I have a huge collection of plums and apricots.
Unlike any other artworks that I've made,...
...these things continuously evolve.
I think one of the reasons why I've been able to keep it going for so long...
...is that every year, it's something new.
And when you come out here and the trees are all in blossom,...
...it's really kind of an amazing experience.